Angelina Jolie's high-profile divorce  from Brad Pitt is going through a major  change Angelina in Starr attorney Laura  Wasser officially parted ways angie  spokesperson tells ET she decided to  change counsel but appreciates Laura's  cooperation an earlier report claimed  Wasser wanted out because angie was too  hostile in the past Laura's told us how  she deals with difficult clients I can  kind of spot the crazy so if I say to  somebody this is how I see your case  playing out and they go oh no I will  usually say I don't know that we're a  good fit the switch-up comes just days  after a source told us brad is sickened  that Angelina and her team have gone  public with their battle another source  maintains Angie's focused on healing her  family and continues to support the  reconciliation of the children with Brad  adding that her new attorneys expertise  is in the protection of children  [Music]  [Applause]